devil fruit powers are pretty much the
single most important thing in all of
one piece for the longest time we
thought that Luffy is someone so
strong-willed and fearless that he
somehow overcomes the seemingly weak
powers of his rubber devil fruits again
and again and for most of the story
grinding his way past enemies with way
stronger devil fruit Powers than himself
that is until his epic battle with kaido
where we find out it has actually been
the other way around all along in
reality Luffy has been the person with
possibly the strongest devil fruit in
the story that allows him to turn
anything he imagines into reality
however Shanks gave it a fake name and
so tricked Luffy into using it in its
weakest form for almost the entire story
which in a way makes it even more
impressive that he has managed to come
this far while holding back like 99 of
his true power but that leaves one
really interesting question on the table
that every real one-piece fan has at
least asked themselves once in their
life before what would have happened if
Luffy had eaten another extremely
overpowered a devil fruit as a kids now
of course there are many Ultra powerful
devil fruits in the story to choose from
like an Earth's lightning fruit kaido's
dragon fruit or whitebeard's earthquake
fruits and if you want to see me cover
those fruits in another video soon but
make sure that you're subscribed to the
channel but for today to make things a
little bit easier I've decided on five
devil fruits that I would have just
loved to see Luffy use in the actual
story and these are the devil fruits of
the five Marine Admirals aokiji's ice
fruit kizaru's light fruit akinu's magma
fruit fujitora's gravity fruit and green
bowls Forest fruits and so if Luffy had
eaten each of these five ridiculously
overpowered devil fruits how would the
course of Luffy's Journey have changed
and how would Luffy have used all of
these fruits compared to the Admirals we
begin in Luffy's childhood where Luffy
accidentally eats the devil fruit that
Shanks and his crew have just stolen
from a marine ship and we do know that
Shanks got his hands on Luffy's devil
fruit very much on purpose because it is
very important and so to give Luffy a
different devil fruit let's just assume
that Shanks has not only one but two
devil fruits with him and instead of the
purple rubber fruit hungry kid Luffy
eats this second one now as you might
know all the Admirals devil's food
Powers share one similarity they belong
to a category called Loki devil fruits
which turned their users entire body
into a force of nature The Only
Exception here is fujitora's gravity
fruit because we actually don't know if
it is also a logia fruit like the others
or just a regular ability that has no
effect on his body whatsoever and for
the sake of this video we will just go
with a regular fruit just to make things
a little bit more interesting and so
depending on each fruit when Luffy eats
the devil fruit by accident and Shanks
grabs him instead of his arm stretching
Luffy's body reacts differently here for
the ice fruit he would probably freeze
Shanks his arm for the light fruit
Shanks his hand just passes through
Luffy for the magma fruit Shanks Burns
himself trying to touch Luffy for the
gravity fruit Shanks is suddenly smashed
into the grounds and for the forest
fruit Luffy just Sprouts a little flower
on his head and his feet grow roots into
the wooden floor of the pup while Shanks
would give that fruit to Luffy's future
brother Ace the son of Goldie Roger the
former pirate king who was also shanks's
former captain in case you wonder why I
actually made a whole video on what
would happen if Luffy was never boring
where I explain in a lot of detail why
Shanks was originally looking for Ace to
give him his devil fruit and how Luffy
accidentally eating it changed his and
Roger's entire plans I strongly
recommend you check that one out later
but yeah for our scenario right here
Luffy has now eaten a powerful logia
devil fruit and Ace is the one to eat
the Nika fruits now one big question
that we need to ask ourselves is of
course which Shanks still sacrifice his
arm for Luffy and give him his straw hat
if Luffy didn't become the chosen one I
think there's a real argument to be made
here that Shanks would rather try to
inspire Ace to become pirate king on the
other hand shanks really took a liking
to Luffy even before he even ate that
devil fruit and I think he would still
come to save Luffy especially after he
was willing to fight the mountain
Bandits to defend their red hair Pirates
honor so yes I do think Shanks would
still save Luffy and Inspire him to
become a great pirate just because he
likes Luffy however I think that in this
specific scenario I think that Shanks
would decide to keep his arm in steps
Ace would most likely not want his
father Straw Hat because he blamed Roger
for all his suffering in life in case
you didn't know Luffy's head used to
belong to Roger before he gave it to
Shanks and so I think it's fair to
assume that even in this case Luffy
would still end up getting his iconic
straw hats after that Luffy's childhood
stays pretty much the same only that he
now learns to use his logia fruit Powers
instead of rubber Powers who now belong
to his brother Ace so let's now get to
the juicy bit and jump 10 years into the
future where Luffy leaves his home
Island to start his own crew with 4 out
of the 5 fruits he would probably just
leave in the same small boat and end up
in the barrel on Kobe's ship again if
luffied out kiji's nice fruit however I
think he would be powerful enough after
10 years of training to freeze the ocean
under his feet and simply start walking
across the ocean similar to how aokiji
uses his ability to bike across the
water but even that case I think he
would probably still get lost and
somehow end up running into Kobe now one
thing that we gotta address is that with
Luffy having such overpowered abilities
the journey through the East blue is
even easier than it was before Luffy
defeats alvida Morgan buggy Kuro Don
Creek and arlong with ease who have
absolutely no chance against any out of
his five abilities because we can assume
that none of these enemies have actually
mastered any form of haki they wouldn't
even be able to touch Luffy and even if
we're talking about Luffy having the
gravity Powers he would simply Crush any
of them under a pile of rubble before
they could even come close to him in
fact there is only one a real obstacle
for this version of Luffy before before
entering the grand line and that is
smoker now in case you forgot smoker is
Luffy's Marine rival throughout the
first half of the story and the first
logia fruit user we meet in general and
since Luffy won't Master hockey until
the second half of the story he can only
win against another logia food user if
his element is the natural weakness of
his opponent's elements however not only
that but on top of this smoker also
carries this very unique weapon because
the tip of it has been coated in a
material called C prism stone that
nullifies any devil fruit ability that
means that even the Untouchable bodies
of a logia fruit user would suddenly
become solid again and so just like in
the main storyline a Luffy would not be
able to beat smoker Woods has no effect
on smoke whatsoever ice and magma can
maybe create some sort of wind to mess
with smoker a little bit but I don't
think that it would be enough to
actually stop or even defeat him and
since smoke is also extremely light
Luffy would need to have mastered his
gravity powers to an incredibly high
level so that he could affect smoker
here at all which I honestly think would
be kind of unlikely instead Dragon once
again has to step in and save his son
from The Marine The Only Exception here
I think would be kizaru's light fruit
because it is so fast that Luffy would
be able to run away from smoker and
maybe even blind him to get away and as
you'll see as we enter the first half of
the grand line this will be a sort of
pattern until we finally start to face
characters who know hockey and until
Luffy learns haki himself enemies that
seem to have no hockey abilities
whatsoever such as Walpole or morya have
no chance against Luffy because they
literally still can't touch him does Rob
Lucci and the rest of zp9 have hockey
before the time skip well on the one
hand it would be strange if they did not
given that they are special forces but
at the same time there is no hint
whatsoever that any of them is using any
form of hockey during their battle with
the straw hats on anuslobby and so I
really think that only gravity Luffy
would have any trouble at all all with
Lucci although even then Luffy would
probably be still powerful enough to
take him down and probably collapse all
of Anna's lobby with him so instead the
real challenges during this part of the
journey until we come to the war at
Marine Fort are of course the other
logia users in the story starting off
with the one and only sir crocodile the
main antagonist of the alabaster Saga
now as you probably remember crocodile
has eaten the dryness or sandlogya devil
fruit and Luffy was only able to beat
him by coding himself in water and his
own blood since humidity is dryness's
natural weakness so how would logia
Luffy without any haki do against
crocodile well it really comes down to
the matchups Luffy having aokiji's ice
powers for instance should absolutely be
able to win ice is quite solid and you
can simply dry it out like a puddle of
water for instance and at the same time
given the high temperatures in the
desert country of alabaster Luffy would
be slightly melting on the surface all
the time I'm imitating the same effect
he used to defeat crocodile in the
actual story with Greenbelt devil fruit
on the other hand Luffy would have been
defeated pretty much in an instant I
mean Luffy's Forest Powers would be
absolutely
Bliss in the desert and even worse
against crocodile who would be able to
Simply dry up any of Luffy's attacks and
Luffy himself similarly the light fruit
would also be pretty much ineffective
against crocodile who on top of all this
most likely also has some form of haki
at this point in the story as well and
so in both of these cases Luffy would
have had to resort to the very same
water trick as in the main storyline if
Luffy had gravity Powers I do think that
he would have a quite decent chance to
hurt crocodile simply by crushing him
into the ground sand particles or knots
and the almighty magma food would simply
melt crocodile sand and overwhelm it
like this we know that because crocodile
managed to block one of al-qaina's
attacks during Marine for it but was
trying to get away from the Admiral as
fast as possible to avoid taking any
more damage now NL on the other hand
would be a completely different story
the lightning fruit is arguably one of
the five strongest devil fruits in the
entire story and one of the most
powerful logia fruits out there now in
the main storyline Luffy was able to
beat NL because of his rubber features
that made him immune to electricity but
how would Luffy have done against NL
with a different devil fruit the light
fruit for instance at first glance seems
quite similar to nl's powers and you
might think that light and electricity
wouldn't really affect each other much
but then again light is just the
byproduct of high energy and heat so you
could think of light Luffy as a living
light bulb that could absorb all of
anal's lightning and then turn it into
more energy himself similarly Forest
Luffy would not be able to touch edel at
all in return we have seen that enel is
more than capable of destroying plants
and trees with his crazy lightning bolts
and if we're being honest So Far
greenbull's Forest fruit seems to be the
worst option for Luffy as for light and
magma these could arguably go either way
depending how these Powers actually work
in one piece for aokiji's ice power
course if adult's powers are stronger
than Luffy's then the heat from his
electricity would start melting Luffy
and the more water there is on Luffy's
body surface the more electricity it
conducts and the quicker Luffy gets
defeated by it on the other hand if
Luffy's ice powers are as crazy as
aokiji's colds can actually slow down
electrons and that would basically
reduce anodes electricity powers to
nothing similarly having a kainu's magma
Powers Luffy could turn the area around
him into hard Rocky ground which doesn't
conduct any electricity however magma
itself since a hot liquid technically
actually conducts electricity extremely
well so who would win well I think in
both of these cases it really comes down
to who is more experienced with their
devil fruit power similar to how both
aokiji and akina would have been able to
overpower Each Other Extreme colds can
make magma useless while extreme hot can
melt ice it's really a question of
endurance and power after this of course
there are also the two encounters with
aokiji on Long ring islands and kizaru
on Saba ODI now we could have gone
through the entire physics here again
but the truth is clearly both of them
would have been way more skilled with
their logia fruits than Luffy at this
point and on top of that they all have
extremely powerful hockey so I do not
think that Luffy and the straw hats
would have had any real chance against
either of them here then we have Luffy's
encounter with Blackbeard and imple down
now Blackbeard is really interesting
because his Darkness fruit is supposedly
the strongest logia fruit out there
however on the other hand it doesn't
behave like a logia fruit at all
Blackbeard's Darkness has strong
properties of both gravity and
absorption he can pull things towards
and into him and on top of that when he
touches someone physically Blackbeard is
able to nullify all of their devil fruit
Powers so really we'll have to wait and
see if this fruit truly is a logia fruit
or whether it might not be something
else similar to Luffy's real fruits now
it would seem like Luffy having keys
whose light Powers would be perfect
against Darkness however we know that
just like a black hole even light can't
escape from Blackbeard's Darkness on the
other hand teach is extremely vulnerable
to any physical attack so especially the
gravity fruit would seem like a quite
capable option of taking him down here
since it's the only fruit where
Blackbeard could not make actual contact
with Luffy's body to nullify his powers
and if Luffy could actually manage to
stop teej right here that would of
course change a whole lot of things in
the actual story even fantastic
for the ward Marine Forge really any of
Luffy's new powers would be of much more
use than his rubber Powers were in the
main timeline and I think that
especially greenbolt's Forest fruit
would absolutely shine here for the very
first time ever after all it is
particularly useful when attacking a
large number of weaker enemies so Luffy
can just take out hold squads of marine
soldiers at once absorbing their energy
to heal himself he could also use his
roots to sneakily free Ace much faster
giving him a much better chance to
actually survive all of this and as a
bonus on top we do know that the forest
fruit is actually not weak to fire
surprisingly something that greenbolt
shows us when momonoski tries to set him
on fire during wano and so overall Luffy
would have a way better chance standing
up to a kainu and causing a little bit
of trouble for him however overall Luffy
would only become a true monster with
all these devil fruits after honing his
skills with them for two years with
Rayleigh and combining them with hockey
and so after the time skip Luffy would
once again go through the first three
enemies with ease Fishman Island Caesar
on Punk Hazard and even though Flamingo
and resrosa would stand not even the
slightest chance against any of these
five luffies and not only that I think
Luffy would also have no problem taking
out katakuri and in case of the magma
fruit you could even argue that Luffy
would be able to put up a real fight
against big mom at that point already he
definitely would not have been captured
by big mom's Army and if he had had the
ice fruit fleeing whole cake Island
would also have been a real piece of
cake so the real question is of course
what would have happened against kaido
in wano let's say Luffy also awakens his
devil fruit there once again now
admittedly we don't quite know yet what
an awaken lokia fruit is truly capable
of but it's very likely that many of the
crazy islands in the grand line were
actually shaped by awakened logia fruit
users in the past so here's my
prediction for each of the five fruits I
think that Forest Luffy would once again
lose quite terribly no way that trees
and plants would be able to seriously
damage kaido with his wind blades and
hardened skin Luffy with the magma fruit
could go either way I think I mean
akinos fruit awakens sounds pretty truly
terrifying but then again kaido can fly
although he did end up in magma in the
end to be fair but we'll see Luffy with
kidaro's fruit would have a pretty
decent chance to win a thing I mean if
Luffy advances his Armament hockey and
conquers hockey as much as in the main
storyline he should be both fast and
powerful enough with his light powers to
take kaido out and similarly he could
use both gravity and Ice to keep kaido
out of the air and slowly grind him down
over time the gravity fruit would of
course be super useful to bombard kaido
with meteors but that would also destroy
the entire island of onigashima so it
might actually be a little bit of a
drawback here and in any case I would
argue that after wano Luffy's actual
devil fruit has turned out to be even
more powerful than any of these five
anyways so maybe the much more
interesting question to ask here is not
what would have happened if Luffy did
all the same stuff but with a different
devil fruit but but instead what would
have happened to the one piece world if
Luffy with his legendary devil fruit had
been allowed to join Shanks and his crew
as a kiss because that one is a much
much more crazy timeline than this one
if you're curious you can watch that one
right here thanks for watching